[Music]
boots to ground is never
gonna be a thing ever again
damn it sledgehammer infinity war
activision please please
innovate for the next call of duty okay
hey guys are you guys witnessing this
game
get off this [ __ ] gaming [ __ ] franchise
this game's [ __ ] terrible okay
but imagine if we take that experience
you know and love
and we spin it on its head and we drop
you into a large
massive world where you have to survive
to be the last man standing you can just
get a feel for when a game is really
good
in this game just you know when you put
it all together either you got a good
game or you don't
and this is a really good game
no get the [ __ ] off
get in there oh he gets it
i got
[Music]
come
him
[Music]
the battle royale genre was the biggest
to burst into gaming for
years and it immediately made an impact
and here you have it guys the 2018
pro-am
fortnite tournament winners
congratulations guys so much
by 2018 the idea of putting a ton of
players onto a massive map with random
weapons and a shrinking playable area
became the genre's defining elements
but battle royales also had a lot of
potential for diverse gameplay
games like playerunknown's battlegrounds
had a slower tactical feel to them
three gear came on he's creeping he's
boxing manages to get it and he gets the
flush onto it so now it is a 1v1 between
moody and k-mine moody takes a lot of
damage
back up onto this keep in mind cloud9
has been under duress for so long
somehow they survived fortnite showcased
a completely different aesthetic and the
added dimension of building made for
incredible highlights
[Music]
[ __ ]
even some games that made less of a
splash had some unique elements
ones that helped players consider what a
battle royale game could be
at the same time the call of duty series
previous title world war
ii had disappointed fans the return of
so-called boots on the ground
gameplay and the 1940s setting hadn't
tipped the scales against obnoxious
features like the hq
a social space that players were
initially forced to load into before
they could even
queue into a game but know the real
innovation call of duty bothers with
is the most insulting kind
a new manipulative social loot box
system
that's exactly what happened when my
grandpa was on the front lines
this thing just flew down and the
[ __ ] cards flew out of the [ __ ]
box and everybody was like
oh you got a [ __ ] grip
oh you got another grip that looked just
like your grip
from the previous one the game also took
few gameplay risks
simplifying both perks and maps and
failed to hold the attention of
streamers for long
so maybe it wasn't too surprising when
call of duty's blackout battle royale
mode was announced as part of black ops
4 black ops 4 is the game that lets you
play with your friends in more ways than
ever before
and we all love black ops for that
combat experience
but imagine if we take that experience
you know and love
and we spin it on its head and we drop
you into a large
massive world where you have to survive
to be the last man standing
but there was one question on everyone's
mind what would
call of duty bring to the genre but for
us to even consider this kind of
experience
it had to be unique and done in a way
only black ops could do now we are doing
this
but we are doing it the black ops way
this was especially pressing because
black ops 4
would also be the first call of duty
game to feature no
single player campaign whatsoever for
fans who would enjoy the plot twist of
the coveted black ops franchise
it was a shocking move but one that
treyarch defended as a natural step
when black ops 4 released in october of
2018 it was met with
generally positive reviews and the
blackout mode was
no exception reviewers praised the
blending of call of duty's gunplay and
arsenal with the format
the major locations on the huge map were
familiar to many fans of the series
but maybe most importantly some huge
names
played the game on release and
immediately put cod
on the radar for battle royale players
oh player i'm whipping
[Applause]
the game also seemed like it could be an
opportunity for new faces to break into
the battle royale scene
faces like liam jukie's james it's like
going into coming in coming
up to that game coming out with the game
was world war ii beforehand
so i was playing stage industry and then
it was like it's going to be a battle
royale on the new
call of duty black ops 4. so then
yeah like you said yes i just knew
there's a window opportunity so like i
wanted to like take that
like until i took it to the next level
like i was grinding that every day for
like 12 hours for months and months and
months and then
i think i was quite good i was quite
good on on the
blackout but there wasn't any
opportunities that came like the
european side
you know like big tournaments and stuff
which which i've done this year
but before long activision added
microtransactions to the game and that
brought questions
how long would blackout even be
supported was this like buying a
fortnite skin which would be good for as
long as the game exists
or was this like buying a call of duty
dlc only to be replaced next year
as games industry critic jim sterling
pointed out it didn't make much sense
but annualized sequels make old news of
previous games and you're expected to
move on and many people do
sure there are people playing on the
older games
i would imagine so especially if they
blew a lot of money on them but the
player base largely moves on
so these are games that want players
spending on them in perpetuity
while also giving them pretty much a
time limit to do it in
before the new hotness comes out and
it's these are two conflicting elements
as far as i'm concerned
and while blackout did manage to bring
battle royale to call of duty
there were a lot of things that could
have been improved the complex inventory
system
still evoked games like pubg and it was
a potential barrier to new players
and while some areas on the map were
callbacks to maps from the series
history
they felt sort of disconnected from each
other the spaces between them seemed a
bit
empty and of course there was still that
initial purchase as a barrier to entry
even with a cheaper version of the game
that didn't include zombies
that business model might have worked in
years past but
times were changing
the call of duty series was in a rough
place and goodwill from players seemed
to be at an all-time
low fans didn't know what to expect
would there ever be
another battle royale in the end the
developers correctly guessed that
despite it being the beginning of the
series cod's roots in 2019 were no
longer based in world war
ii the last bullet in the chamber to
save the series
was modern warfare in the shadows
they send us in to find it
target is in the main house
provost 6 going dark
and with warzone the new game's battle
royale mode that debuted several months
later
call of duty didn't just bounce back it
took over twitch
the game was free and cross platform the
map was new and there were plenty of
fresh touches that brought the game into
a new era you're likely to feel right at
home with many areas of warzone's map
too
if you've already been playing modern
warfare many of its named areas use
identical layouts as those in modern
warfare proper as well as previous
installments
so you can navigate them using muscle
memory and they're intuitive enough to
learn from scratch too
blackout may have brought call of duty
to battle royale but warzone took the
genre to new
and exciting places the inventory was
cleaned up
and simplified and another common
complaint about battle royale is the
impact of pure luck on the outcome was
partially mitigated by the addition of
cash
it could be used to buy kill streaks buy
back fallen squadmates or even bring in
their own custom loadout and if a player
was eliminated early enough
they could get a second chance at life
by winning a 1v1
gulag match
oh i'm gonna mail
like blackout it was a battle royale
experience that cod players could enjoy
huge names from across the series
history found a game that viewers were
happy to watch
28 plus 13 is 53 wait 48 plus 15 is 63.
did we just get 63
but perhaps more importantly it was a
cod experience that the battle royale
players with the biggest fan bases were
willing to try you can just get a feel
for when a game is really good or not
and this game just kind of has it all
there's a flow and a pace the
the guns the map uh the movement
um when you put it all together either
you got a good game or you don't
and this is a really good game the
result for the game massive twitch
viewership and
unprecedented buy-in from its players
just three days after the game's release
in march 2020
it achieved 15 million downloads by
early august
it had over 75 million and tournaments
even started popping up run by community
figures like nick marks
activision even began sponsoring the
nick merc's mfam tournaments promoting
them and contributing towards their
prize pool
and the game was a big opportunity for
up and comers too
jukie shot to the top of the earners
list in warzone's early competitive
history
and had a chance to play with all sorts
of cod legends like
sensor i feel like it's my game no way
like say i was playing multiplayer with
censor
i'd listen i'd want him to tell me what
to do and like help me
but on war zone when i was playing with
him in the m family of the night he was
like
say okay he's getting this car where do
you want to go check he's like don't go
get a uav
drive there where do you want to go and
he was just playing around me and like
i was popping up i dropped 330 kills
in a row like in that tournament and it
was all
simply because like center was just
playing around me and was always
for players like him the game is more
than another yearly card release
it's a lifeline to a competitive career
in a title that has traditionally been
dominated by north american pros
[Applause]
but in may 2020 infinity ward studio
narrative director taylor kurasaki
confirmed that warzone was going to make
call of duty history
unlike blackout warzone would receive
updates and continue to live
as a standalone title when i found out
that i was so happy like
because it just made me just want to
grind more really and just want to just
keep going
in the same direction but i was
literally so excited when i found out
that
because i love this game and i love the
way my stream and stuff pops off with it
so like
it's really it's just exciting really to
know that it's coming you know what i
mean
call of duty warzone still has plenty of
challenges
the game's anti-cheat has been
criticized as hackers terrorize for
dansk
wait hold on hold on i might be able to
kill him hold on hold on hold on
oh my god oh my god
from that far away oh my god
it's missing some features like custom
lobbies that could push the game over
the top
as a spectator experience although if
the call of duty league's experiment
with war zone weekends is any indication
the developers are aware of the demand
before yeah wait wait is that stressing
they have to jump out tens jumps out
there's havoc
it's one player left the c4
the esports future of the game is
uncertain too and with so much already
invested in the call of duty league
it's hard to say whether warzone will
get a world cup on par
with a title like fortnite and of course
players have yet to see
how exactly future call of duty titles
will integrate into warzone
and whether the plug will be pulled
years from now to make room for another
battle royale
but one thing is already clear call of
duty warzone has
reshaped the landscape for battle
royales and most importantly in 2020 it
gave call of duty a different path
forward
one that has reached more players than
ever for some
that means learning about the next call
of duty inside warzone a move familiar
to battle royale players but which
nonetheless meets your players where
they are
in the game for other players like
jukies it means an
end to the wager matches he used to pay
the bills with early in his career
instead he'll be sporting the colors of
london's cdl franchise
the royal ravens
but what seems certain now is that the
unholy alliance of passionate call of
duty fans
battle royale die hards and free to play
thrill seekers
have changed the series forever he's on
the
front side but get ripped
[Laughter]
yes
that's so good and that
no matter what future titles bring a
huge battle in a little ex-soviet
backwater called verdansk
may have just saved call of duty
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]
you